[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
avec un sommaire formidable puisque nous
allons parler de la radicalisation ne
vont pas dessus du malaise des banlieues
de la grève évidemment du 5 décembre des
violences faites aux femmes
et peut-être aussi du black friday pour
rencontre le battre black friday c'est
le débat qui divise la france
actuellement et pour en parler je vais
revis d'appuyer rust
bonjour ça va très bien merci tout le
monde connait le rappeur mais vous êtes
aussi le fondateur de beaulieu active
vous êtes aussi réalisateur et on va
parler d'un court métrage que vous avez
réalisé sur la radicalisation et puis
vous êtes aussi mordus du conseil
économique et social je dois le préciser
voilà gtdi environnementale et
environnementalistes ont maintenant 10
et environnemental c'est vrai compatible
[Rires]
je vois des savoirs et écrivain
corriette combien une vingtaine de
livres moindre je suis dans mon
vingtième notre 20e dont notamment une
biographie alors de molière qui était un
best-seller mais qu'ils ont toujours et
vous êtes le seul parmi nous je pense je
mets estimer personne qui à lui tout
cela mais j'ai eu cette chance
j'ai cette chance parce que j'ai été
accidenté j'ai passé 18 mois l'hôpital
550 nuit donc il faut trouver
donc si vous voulez lire cela vous savez
quoi faire
pour son livre the life être à l'hôpital
donc donc c'est parfait
florence faire cas des sautés bonjour
vous êtes sur la crise et au barreau de
versailles jour toujours changer bon
alors si je veux dire j'ai une moto
comment vous avez fait pour arriver à
l'hôpital mais soyez prudents et jean
servat choisi bonjourbonjour éditeurs
des éditions la joie ni toujours avec un
livre d'ailleurs dénoncé remporter parce
que c'est sur la banlieue
ah bah oui c'était d'actualité quand il
était d'actualité ça vient de sortir
dans que alors intéressant c'est au
voile disserte de rost par exemple vient
marquer tu ira au paradis et thuir est
au paradis c'est le ces deux titres de
ce court métrage qu'on peut voir
actuellement fait d'ailleurs la tournée
un peu en france c'est un court métrage
de coûts des réalités avec thomas que
marien cumule que mu riant et ça qui est
avec smaïn herriot vega on va regarder
peut-être laborde à dos et puis on en
parle tout de suite après
hop
[Musique]
shereni adapté je te dérange là c'est
tout ça hein les gars je t'accompagne
alors l'histoire vous la raconter c'est
l'histoire d'un jeune radicaliser qui
est l'initiateur d'explosifs et qui est
prêt à commettre un attentat et qui
tombe sur le personnage joué par saïd
qui va l'autre était fier de lui un
théâtre oui c'est ça évoqué en suspens a
évidemment son humour et bien il ya ce
décompte de 20 minutes
l'un qui est lancée par le reste du
commando et ce jeune va va rencontrer
smaïn qui va peut-être faire changer ses
plans
et pour nous c'est important parce que
les rencontres font parfois basculer une
vie d'un côté exactement donc on va on
va suivre l'itinéraire de ceux de ce
gosse et à travers le cette rencontre
aller smaïn on va comprendre aussi
certaines choses la question des
familles monoparentales qui aujourd'hui
il reste pour moi le il y avait un
investissement à faire fondamental
aujourd'hui le premier est une des
causes et je pense que alors c'est
évidemment les ailes à la question du
terrorisme est beaucoup plus complexe
que ça nous on n'a pas la prétention à
travers ce film de l'analyse et de la
première amours d'un gamin conscient
d'ailleurs on voit sa fragilité dont le
dans le dans le film et puis au fur et à
mesure on essaye de comprendre comment
il en est d'ailleurs l'une des premières
questions qui arrive c'est que fait le
jeune à la fin parce que le film se
termine à la fin surprend les gens en
général et leur faut deux trois minutes
pour sortir duel du film et non c'est un
court métrage c'est un 12 minutes 12 mai
les toits et s'aimer c'est une opération
coup de poing qu'on a voulu faire c'est
on va le voir où ce film nous tourner là
depuis depuis le mois de mars
je fais une tournée à travers la france
là on va partir dans les outre-mer on a
le canada aussi des demandes sur le
canada et la belgique qu'on va attaquer
aussi derrière donc on fait on essaye de
projeter le film est d'ouvrir le débat
avec les jeunes un peu partout on veut
parler de pardon parce que vous vous ai
parlé de familles monoparentales en
disant qu'il y avait un investissement à
faire feu et développer oui parce que
moi c'est enfin je pense que c'est un
enjeu important
je vais vous laisser ma place non mais
il par dire il ya un investissement peu
non mais c'est vrai pour parler de ça
mais c'est vrai que le fait que en effet
y ait pas de famille et pas d'éducation
et de la solitude c'est ses enfants
c'est une des parties de une partie
importante des explications de deux de
ces dérives parfois bien sûr vous avez
vous savez quand vous avez des ados et
vous vivez dans certains quartiers qui
sont propices
malheureusement au côté obscur d'aider
des choses vous avez des familles où la
femme travaille et s'occupe des enfants
et c'est très compliqué quand vous avez
des ados et surtout quand vous avez
plusieurs enfants à gérer c'est pas
évident donc c'est le moment où on a le
plus de possibilité de basculer
et quand vous tombez sur des gens qui
vous emmène dans dans ses délires là
vous avez beaucoup beaucoup de mal à à
gérer et je pense que la question que ce
soit sur les questions de délinquance
que ça soit sur les questions
la réussite même d'ailleurs scolaire je
pense qu'il est aujourd'hui il faut que
les pouvoirs publics prennent vraiment
la mesure de ces questions de famille
monoparentale et c'est sûrement
l'absence du père un absolument mieux
bien sûr mais justement de la figure
tutélaire vous perdez vous n'est plus là
donc souvent ces cinq ans
nos parental ses sept millions de ses
sept millions de français je crois bien
aux français c'est considérable c'est
considérable
avec peut-être encore une proportion
plus forte dans certains dans sa chair
mon quartier évidemment on connaît le
nombre de radicaliser ou pas alors j'ai
pas le chiffre exact des radicalisé mais
en tout cas il ya il ya toute une
mouvance un moment où avec beaucoup de
jeunes qui sont partis en syrie dont
certains d'ailleurs sont revenus nous on
a fait pendant pendant deux ans j'ai
travaillé avec une autre association
avec laquelle on intervenait dans les
prisons et or et donc il y avait déjà
des retours de syrie évidemment je vais
vous dire ça c'est la déradicalisation
entre guillemets ça ne sert absolument à
rien d'ailleurs ils ont fini par
comprendre les pouvoirs publics là
dessus et c'est pour ça que nous on est
on est parti sur le mérite et de
stationner sur la question narnia pas
sur la question de la prévention il elle
est fondamentale et on a rencontré une
femme qui est extraordinaire qui
s'appelle muriel domenach qui était à la
tête du série pdr qui est la cellule du
ministère de l'intérieur qui s'occupe de
ça et qui malheureusement est parti
aujourd'hui mais qui avait compris que
l'investissement il doit être vraiment
sur la question de la prévention de ce
que vous dites est ce que c'est
important c'est à dire que on va avoir
quand même des retours d'un certain
nombre de djihadiste français et vous
dites là c'est trop tard enfin 5 oublié
côté de moi je sais que j'ai rencontré
en tout cas il ya une grande partie que
j'ai rencontré en prison
sincèrement je pense que le jour où
certains sortent on est mort qu'est-ce
qu'on déverse à l'intérieur c'est pas à
moi de dire ce qu'ils font mais on peut
dire c'est pas bien des radicalisé mais
au moins on essaye alors que je suis
d'accord avec vous mais évidemment c'est
faux il sait sauf que le aujourd'hui le
processus savait-on délit vous avez des
gens qui ont été sur ces territoires ont
commis des atrocités
certains de couper des têtes 700 vous
d'aller on a vu les images l'émission
ces images sont donc ne ressort pas
indemne bien évidemment exactement mais
aussi sur les enfants qui rentrent aussi
les infos que les enfants qui rentrent
de cyril fola faut mettre le paquet
parce qu'ils ont vu des choses atroces
ce qu ils ont eu des armes entre les
mains et là il ya du travail
et là je pense que les dispositifs
d'ailleurs du goût du gouvernement sur
ces questions là il va falloir peut-être
les gérer autrement ce que ces gosses il
faut les accompagner il faut qu'il soit
il soit dans des structures qui soit
adaptée et qu'on les accompagne et que
ont une rupture déjà avec la famille
sinon je pense qu on on a une bombe à
retardement
là il y en a pas mal d'enfants qui sont
placés dans des familles d'accueil
absolution c'est une algue mais c'est
quand même assez admirable
est-ce que ça doit être très compliqué
donc fois peut-être accompagné aussi ces
familles d'accueil pour qu'elle faisait
les épaules aussi pour les soutenir et
les sortir de la famille surtout mes
parents venir parce que c'est ça est la
prévention au fond puisque saleuses du
film qu'est ce qu'on sait du processus
de radicalisation justement comment ça
se passe parce que on dit souvent
et c'est pas idiot il expliqué dire
qu'il y en a peut-être donné dans une
société où il ya plus tellement plus
d'idéal tellement plus de choses pour se
battre que parfois on trouve alors c'est
pas la bonne raison pour se battre mais
peut-être que ça de leur donne un idéal
qui n'ont pas ailleurs qui est celui de
la consommation du breuil du des 'black
friday' etc
vous savez moi j'ai je pense qu'on se
connaît assez pour vous sachez le
parcours que j'ai et les combats que
j'ai menés sur ces questions là
justement on a toujours été sur la ligne
à partir du moment où vous avez des
gamins qui n'ont aucune perspective qui
n'ont pas d'horizon
là il ya une expression que j'ai utilisé
souvent c'est que je moi même d'ailleurs
j'ai vécu dans cet état d'esprit c'est à
dire que pour nous l'avenir se limiter à
la minute d'après isaac est ce qu'on va
faire
au total elle suit exactement et quand
vous êtes dans cette dynamique là quand
vous avez le sentiment que vous n'avez
plus rien à perdre
il n'y a rien de plus dangereux que
quelqu'un qui a le sentiment qui n'a
plus rien à perdre
et quand vous avez là où la république
est absente les obscurantistes
prolifèrent et arrivent et leur font des
promesses on leur dit vous allez aller
combattre
vous allez on vous valorise à travers sa
et les être quelqu'un besoin de
d'électricien exactement
et donc ces gamins-là souvent se laisse
embrigader de cette manière là et se
retrouve là-bas alors la réalité là bas
elle est beaucoup plus complexe parce
que quand on compte on en parle avec
certains c'est un traumatisme pour
certaines mais
un peu déjà fait des promesses et un
monde qui n'est pas celui-là partisane
serment après des violences terribles
enfin c'est ça le titre d'ailleurs ce
qu'on leur progresse assez telle
position
alors vous êtes plutôt tendance
chrétienne
c'est vrai que ce manque d'idéal ce
manque de chose à quoi croire c'est un
dd non nous aurons des dérives de notre
société
nous entrons dans la période de l'avent
marchons vers noël dans le presse de
mettre douala car il a dû perdre aux
répondants l'avant nous nous nous
marchons vers noël et la lumière dans
nouméa black friday est ce que je veux
dire ce que je veux dire c'est que les
idéaux les la connectique est plus d
idéal pour lequel se bat pas ce que
disent et la miss mais est-ce que tu
termines été laminés parce que dick et
laminé d'une part et d'autre part nous
avons un phénomène une accélération du
temps qui fait que l'actualité à son
effet d'essuie glace et qu' on ne peut
plus s'arrêter en dix ans prenons un
moment de silence
prenons un moment de grandeur regardons
la beauté aujourd'hui vous voyez les
touristes qui rentre dans une cathédrale
et ils passent leur temps avec leur
smartphone pour être sûr d'avoir le
selphy ou pour être sûr d'avoir vu les
détails mais ne regarde pas il ne
contemple pas aujourd'hui il faut
redonner l'envi le goût de contempler de
partage et de regarder d'écouter de se
taire un peu curieux comme de dire qu'il
ya plus d'idéal fin que l'on parle il ya
treize soldats français qui viennent de
mourir et qui étaient engagés et quand
on est dans l'armée c'est bien qu'on a
un idéal l'idéal de servir sa patrie de
servir à l on met donc ne
ne globez les ont pas en disant il ya
plus d'idéal sûr surtout au jour il ya
13 titres qui sont morts pour justement
défendre cet idéal
quel plus beau voilà comment comment
vous créez un idéal pour des gens qui
vivent dans des situations où on a où il
ya aucune perspective d'accord on est
d'accord mais tout le monde
heureusement il ya hélas beaucoup trop
de monde et beaucoup trop de gens qui
n'ont pas de perspective qu'ils soient
qui vivent dans des quartiers pourris et
et qui n'ont soit disant pas aucun
avenir
heureusement tout le monde ne devient
pas de djihadistes heureusement vous
avez une arrêtons comme de caricaturer
c'est vrai tout à fait raison c'est un
véritable problème mais tout le monde ne
voit pas la lumière en syrie chacun a
son propre idéal donc on est sur des
idéaux individuel idéal collectif
donc en fait comme on est dans son
individus en sont le mondial individuel
on va pas s'occuper
on ferme les yeux on se tait y en bouche
les oreilles par rapport à toutes ces
problématiques de banlieue puis on est
dans son idée à la soirée j'attends
quand même franchement oui
alors qu'il ya du mouvement associatif
formidable en france qui passe beaucoup
de choses il ya aussi beaucoup de gens
qui se bat quand même je pense au fait
partie d'une association de ce genre là
il ya beaucoup de gens qui est oui à la
hauteur de ses actifs qui se battent
pour ça et ce serait bien de parler
justement de ce qui fonctionne beaucoup
de choses cruciales ont fait doucement
au 10e tour de france à m avec ce court
métrage
vous rencontrez dans beaucoup de gens il
ya les gens que vous avez rencontré du
ministère de l'intérieur de vous parler
on sait comment lutter justement contre
la radicalisation l'ordi faut lutter
contre les familles monoparentales mais
ça c'est pas con terme
là c'est un vrai problème de fond mais
est-ce que à court terme on sait comment
faire sans oui parce qu'ils y allaient
enfin les services font leur boulot
alors là la différence des du terrorisme
à l'époque qui étaient organisés en
réseau avec des réseaux qui était à
l'étranger qui pilotait les choses
aujourd'hui c'est différent ce qui fait
le plus peur c'est le terrorisme de
mimétisme
c'est à dire que n'importe qui peut
prendre un couteau est allé planter cet
âge on dans la dernière avec ses salades
exactement ça on voit une addition qui
était qui était autre chose qui s'est
elle quelque chose de très organisé
mais depuis c'est en effet d un 10 et 5
des individus qui seraient car après ça
c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué pour les séries là c'est très
content j'étais prévenir ça oui c'est ça
donc à moins de mettre un policier
derrière tous les citoyens je pense que
c'est beaucoup plus complexe donc ça ça
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que cette ont
enfin compris que le tout répressif
n'est pas la solution
à un moment on nous a dit tolérance zéro
il faut être dans la répression dans la
répression la dans la répression
est ce qu'on a fait baisser la
délinquance nom est ce qu'on a fait
baisser la criminalité pas du tout bien
au contraire
donc il ya un moment il faut revenir aux
fondamentaux c'est à dire il faut de la
répression en ont conduit certains
dépassent le l'alizé rouge
mais la prévention elle est fondamentale
et de se dire que on a peut-être loupé
une génération ou peut-être même deux et
qu'aujourd'hui il faut mettre les moyens
sur les nouvelles générations pour ne
pas reproduire les mêmes erreurs
répression pardon solution non mais je
vous le dit pas mais il faudrait pas
compter que sur la révélation il
faudrait aussi fixé de véritables
limites quand on voit que par exemple on
supporter l'idée que quelqu'un arrête de
serrer la main d'une femme que ce soit à
la ratp à la préfecture de police où
n'importe quoi on accepte le sort du
rouge s'est pas accepter ses passions
ses descriptions toujours à bord on
assure toujours là c'est un problème de
discrimination et de la personne peut
parfaitement du couffin l'employeur peut
licencier une personne qui s'est
systématiquement ils ne le sont pas sur
le sur le sujet des autres reprises par
rapport à la radicalisation qui pose en
effet des problèmes c'est pas facile à
harry il ya de nombreuses entreprises
qui au contraire essaye d'accompagner
plutôt que de dire tu serre pas la main
donc j'étais licencié compagne
l'accompagnement s'est essayé de parler
voilà parler d'écouter de de comprendre
leur montrer que le coran jamais dit que
faut pas serré la main et de dire mais
il faut trouver trouver autre chose
s'ils voulaient pas serré la main vous
pouvez rester courtois dire bonjour
c'est quand même sur l'action accepte
cette idée là si on commence à
comprendre voulait pas serré la main
vous allez le faire un petit signe on
est pertinent mais c'est perdu
c'est perdu non c'est l'absence de
limites si un jour ils resserrent
mais peut-être qu'un jouet dont deux
siècles si vous êtes dans tout répressif
la fifa ne vous reposez précisant la
date d'acceptation d'un truc scandaleux
et vous qui défendez les femmes et les
violences faites aux femmes etc
c'est une violence faite aux femmes
quelqu'un qui reçu de sarnez
les personnes âgées elle dit production
des limites à arrêter de comprendre si
on est systématiquement quand même dans
le répressif à ce que licencier
quelqu'un pour faute grave c'est du
répressif aussi c'est ça le place à deux
journées une promotion comme ça on lui
dira on va comprendre on dit ne
conduisait plus le bus allait dans un
bureau et un défoulement rebondir sur ce
que vous disiez il ya du préventif a
fermé il ya du décloisonnement des
banlieues aussi la grande erreur c'est
qu'il ya plus de mixité
alors qu'ils en avaient une certaine
mixité à une époque mais il ya des gars
qui étaient les quartiers on rentre chez
lui et il ya plus de mixité dont je
pense qu'il faut aussi il ya tout un
travail moi c'est un problème
d'urbanisme et d'organisation de la cité
qui sait ça peut remonter aux années 60
mais là je pense qu'il ya un vrai enjeu
aussi de désenclavement des banlieues et
de d'essayer de faire en sorte que les
bassesses h tout le monde que ça se
passe comme ça
exactement donc voilà ton qu'ils auront
donc ils font leur trou contretemps qui
s'entretuent entre eux cessé il ya aucun
problème c'est quand ça sort de là et
c'est là où je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
pouvoirs publics commencent peut-être à
comprendre que avec d'ailleurs ce qui
s'est passé avec les gilet jaune
ça fait combien d'années qu'on leur dit
qu'il ya une france qui souffre en
silence et qu'on n'entend pas il ya eu
2005 sur les banlieues c'est exactement
la même chose que les gilets jaunes
aujourd'hui les gilet jaune au début
quand ils manifestaient on a dit que
c'est sale et ça allait se passer
et puis finalement quand ils ont
commencé à monter à paris et à tout
casser la les pouvoirs publics se sont
réveillés malheureusement ils font à
chaque fois qu'il y ait des drames comme
ça pour que on se réveille un jour pour
dire il ya des gens qui souffrent on a
parqué les gens des mêmes conditions
sociales dans les mêmes blocs
il faut pas s'étonner on nous parle
après de communautarisme s'assemblent
ferry ça me fait rire parce que vous
avez le bureau de l'homme sait comment
attirer des gens vont aller bon allez
vivre
c'est un travail de longue haleine parce
qu'on a laissé la situation pourrir une
pas tout mélanger parce que franchement
toile et gilet jaune et les gens qui
viennent du fin fond de la banlieue se
pense pas qu'ils aient le moindre point
commun et j'ai jamais vu un gilet un
gilet jaune s'intéresser au sort des
poules des deux groupes de populations
dont vous parlez on n'est pas du tout
dans la même problématique donc là on
sera différée de 40 quand même assez
absent des jolies jambes sur l'accord
heureusement non mais la république la
france est là parce que c'est des deux
c'était conjugués et je les pense que là
aujourd'hui compliquée s'arrêter bien
bien bien bien plus chaud que ça parce
que les lettons les malaises convergent
à un moment donné
c'est plus qu'explosif même là alors il
n'y a pas de mauvaises graines ya que
des mauvais cultivateurs c'est
exactement comme cela et c'est la phase
des misérables et les misérables c'est
le titre de ce film pour pouvoir
actuellement qui avec ses proches au son
de votre corps métal se passer aussi la
situation une certaine situation dans
les banlieues
je propose qu'on regarde la bande
annonce de ce film qui effectue un gros
succès qui représentera peut-être là la
france aux oscars d'ailleurs contrôle de
police
le fais quoi là on attend plus on
attendait le bus 68 cents et c'est bon
si ça va je gère je vous file vous avez
pas droit de faire ça non
mécontente
ici c'est notre vie
toi tu débarques nous ça fait dix ans
qu'on est là on est les seuls à se faire
respecter par les gens disent ils ont
peur de vous c'est tout tu connais saint
quentin volley a new way met la pression
sur les petits faut qu'on retrouve
lannion
arrête toi
[Applaudissements]
vous ne mettrez pas la colère et les
cris
la galère c'est qu'il ya un drôle qui
nous a fini qu'est ce que tu me parles
de gérer un drone lie à un gamin
inconscient là
ce qu'on peut faire tomber la bac avec
cette vidéo sont de les misérables
c'est un fait passé intéressant vous
parliez de 2005
il est tiré de là c'est à dire qu'on
voit comment un petit événement peut
mettre très vite le feu aux poudres
comment une étincelle jaillit et parce
qu' une violence terrible dans dans ses
relations et les misérables c'est très
bien fait parce que c'est l'histoire
d'une patrouille de deux flics qui qui
est en patrouille dans dans cette
banlieue et on voit que les misérables
c'est à la fois les gens qui vivent là
mais c'est aussi des flics des accueils
à 2-2 misère qui c'est qui ce qu'ils se
rencontrent c'est malheureusement c'est
souvent ça aujourd'hui on a on a on a
deux blocs comme deux mondes qui
s'affrontent et ratent des policiers qui
eux sont se sentent abandonnés ont
d'ailleurs pour beaucoup conquis sorte
d'école qu'on emmène dans les quartiers
les plus difficiles en or la i et ii
dans le film ghana qu'il n'est dans les
coins il y en a qui vient du havre
troyes et ben justement oui mais on
alors parce que le film il a rangé de
cette manière la réalité du terrain ce
que vous avez beaucoup de jeunes flics
sont au vert est débarqué là bas et et
qui sont complètement perdus et qu'ils
savent pas comment faire et qui pensent
que par la violence
ils vont réussir à mettre entre
guillemets elle comme on dit à la mangue
l'ailé les jeunes de ces quartiers là et
donc il ya un moment c'est cette
rivalité entre les deux et c'est comme
les profs c'est pareil au lieu de mettre
les gens expérimentés dans ces endroits
là et pas non on a mal démarré parce que
les agrégés votre nom c'est mon lieu de
sensible depuis peuvent rêver tout à
fait j'ai pas si ça marche c'est les
annonces qui ont été faites il ya pas
très longtemps donc la mise en oeuvre
elle n'est pas encore effective
à voir par la suite cela dit c'est un
échec quand même de la politique des
deux villes depuis c'est pas le récent 1
c
et depuis trente ans comme comme dit le
président on a mis un pognon de dingue
ça sert pas à grand chose
alors ça voilà ça ça me met hors de moi
parce que on parle de montagne d'argent
oui il ya de l'argent qui a été mis dans
ces quartiers mais le fléchage laden
d'accord ça a été extrêmement efficace
le fléchage de ces crédits à qui on
remet on donne cet argent qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait on a voulu faire du bâti
d'accord on à rénover les bâtiments
on a oublié qu'il y avait des gens qui
vivaient dans ces badges abonnés en tout
si jamais des regrets tout le monde est
d'accord pour faire le même constat on
double politique de la ville
il ya beaucoup d'argent a été dépensé
non mais on est tous d'accord
c'était mal dépensé voilà donc le canton
les hôpitaux c'est le nom d'ag2
président parlait sagement oui enfin
c'est quand même un effectif
justement laissé jusqu'au xixe n'est pas
si mauvaise que ça parce que non on a
l'impression qu'il faut que au fond la
société qui plus tranquille que celle là
et peur pour qu'on prenne conscience de
ce qui se passe dans ces banlieues vous
adapter sa taille elle avait un très
beau livre qui s'appelait enfants des
vieux banhi celui lié bannissez la
banlieue entre exactement ce sens
étaient les lieux me aubry
donc je pense que les politiques à un
moment quand ils sont au pouvoir ils
sont tellement déconnectés de la réalité
qu'ils sont incapables de comprendre ce
qui se passe combien de fois
combien de gens à un moment issus de ces
environnements ont voulu prendre en main
leur destin et qui ont été voir les
politiques qui ont essayé de leur
proposer des choses ils ont toujours
considéré et c'est ça moi qu'aujourd'hui
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles je
commence d'ailleurs à lever un peu le
pied aussi après avoir sacrifié ma
carrière artistique pour ses engagements
là c'est qu'à un moment on se rend
compte que on nous prend toujours entre
guillemets peau des jeunes qui viennent
de la banlieue dont qui n'ont rien à
rien apporté en tant que tel on appelle
des pseudo-experts des sociologues qui
vont dans ces quartiers qui observe
comme dans un zoo et qui font des
rapports et parce qu'ils y ont passé une
semaine
mais non c'est notre vie c'est notre vie
on est capable georges aujourd'hui
d'inventer des solutions concrètes
alors on a en ce moment un ministre à
ministre qui est julien de normandie une
rave la ville qui est quelqu'un qui est
très à l'écouté
qui dit volontiers qui connaît pas
vraiment ces sujets là mais qu'il est
route et qu'ils consultent beaucoup les
gens qui quittent qui vivent dans ces
quartiers ou qui travaillent et
maintenant est ce qu'on va lui donner
les moyens de faire les choses ça c'est
autre chose et j'ai vu avec le plan
borloo la manière dont on nous a
humiliés avec ce plan voilà c'est très
serré de l'aide c'est resté lettre morte
mais on était scandalisé moi j'ai fait
partie de la commission 1 et bordeaux
étaient partis sur l'idée qu' il fallait
vraiment faire un vrai nettoyage et
quelle était la solution mais il ya
énormément mais ça doit passer par
bordeaux par exemple
oui mais ya pas une seule semaine chez
patrice les problèmes et sont diverses
c'est une convergence d'éléments mais
justement et c'est je parlais de
fléchage tout à l'heure c'est que sur
quelle part des choses on met les moyens
on ne peut pas mettre juste 2 milliards
ici en disant que voilà il faut rénover
les bâtiments
il faut certes rénover les bâtiments
mais qu'est-ce qu'on crée comme
perspective pour les gens qui habitent
là ces jeunes là qui n'ont d'image que
le
dealer de câbles sa grosse voix
exactement qu'est ce qu'on fait donc il
y avait énormément de choses qui étaient
qu'avec qui était dans ce plan qui
aurait pu vraiment servir à au moins
réduire mais drastiquement ses problèmes
dans ces quartiers là et qu'on était à
l'elysée et quand j'ai vu la manière la
première phrase du président de la
république déjà moi j'ai dit je m'en
vais d'ici je quitte la salle parce que
c'était juste une injure à notre
intelligence et à tout le travail qu'on
a fait surtout dans la première phase
mais c'est un deal t1
je vois mal de mâles blancs valeur sur
la même scène en mettant un rapport à
l'autre sur la banlieue
pourquoi vous commandez dans ce cas là
le rapport tente en fait travailler les
gens non mobilisons nous dit on avait
deux mois et demi pour faire pour rendre
leur apport d'eau pour nous avons nous a
pressés pour le polonais 7 20 mâles
blancs de cette offre sur ce sujet n'est
pas votre énoncé très complices et c'est
un sujet extrêmement complexe il ya le
problème de la drogue et le problème de
l'éducation il ya le problème de
l'armement il ya le problème de de la
19e levée de la culture c'est c'est
extrêmement complexe alors on peut
arriver avec des tas d'idées
moi je peux je peux arriver en disant
tiens on va monter une troupe de théâtre
parce que c'est valorisant pour tout le
monde mais on va faire ça dès le collège
et ça ça me passionnerait mais il ya
déjà des initiatives qui se font ya
plein d'initiatives mais comme le
faisait très bien ross
il faut trouver cette convergence et il
faut avoir cette énergie de la
convergence avec des gens mais c'est
très compliqué ça fait 30 ans qu'il ya
une politique de la ville ça fait 30 ans
que ça marche pas et les gens qui ont
fait c'est de mener ces politiques de la
ville
c'était des gens qui avaient de bonnes
intentions dessus donc c'est très
compliqué mais cache misère mais oui
c'est exactement ça cache misère après
pour dépenser sur des gens
parce que vous disiez tous ces gens
quand on est quand même dans une
démocratie et quand même des partis
politiques qui sont un peu en déshérence
enfin on peut militer dit les hommes
politiques sont totalement déconnectés
de la réalité
rien n'empêche personne de militer dans
un parti politique de faire entendre sa
voix de se faire élire de monter des
listes etc
cette noblesse arrêtons de toujours
critiquer le personnel politique on a le
personnel politique qu'on mérite on a le
personnel politique pour lequel on a
voté unis fait sur henin elissalde en
mieux vous fait sourire parce que
combien de gens se sont impliqués
combien de gens ont été dans les partis
politiques
et pourquoi certains ont refusé d'y
aller parce que ces gens là on s'en sert
à partir du moment où ils viennent de la
banlieue et c'est le problème que je
vous disais tout à l'heure on prend
toujours nous on doit faire dix fois
plus même quand on al'expertise des
sujets on a l'impression que on n'est
pas valable parce qu'on vient pas on
n'est pas n'est pas énarque on vient pas
qu'on n'ait pas on n'est pas les fils 2
et que voilà donc moi je vous en parle
en connaissance de cause
bien sûr vous avez accusé parce qu'on
sort de banlieue qu'on a raison aussi
mais jackson m'a dit ça mais voilà donc
j'allais tient la raison exactement
personnes mais soyez tout simple pour
les sauver mais que les gens militent
que les gens s'inscrivent dans des
partis politiques et un éventail
politique qui va de l'extrême gauche à
l'extrême droite
je pense que chacun peut trouver son
bonheur en france ledl d'être
franchement je ne vois pas de quoi
arriver au pouvoir d'après vous chers
amis à moi je trouve parce qu'ils le
méritent mais c'est supposer une
faillite envahissent exactions
tous les deux partie politisée au groupe
et aimant j'ai vu des choses difficiles
à gérer
c'est la politique qui n'ont jamais mais
jamais de leur vie ils s'intéressaient
et qui la macro en arrivant au départ
tout à au monde la campagne ce qu'il
apportait c'était ce renouveau la
dynamique qu'il apportait on se disait
oui il va y avoir de la diversité on
disait oui qui va y avoir des jeunes qui
vont arriver ça sera plus le mâle blanc
de 54 ans qui qui est qu'avec son
costume et sa cravate qui quitte à
québec le bal blanc 2,5 mais non mais
gentiment des passionnés macro et voilà
on n'a déjà plus le droit on n'a plus le
droit 80-78 dont la plus drôle service
public alors une cinquantaine une
soixantaine d'hommes politiques et de
femmes politiques à y passer qu'un sûr
dans les banlieues qu'ils y dorment
qu'ils y mange qui côtoient les gens qui
seraient déchus onze ans que je leur
propose à chaque fois je les prend à
partie sur les plateaux et je le redis
nominé enfin paris en cortège en
personne s'est pas venez mais c 'est pas
ses pages à faire l'aller-retour s'est
ouvert le monde est rempli de gens de
d'extraction extrêmement humble je dire
le ministre faisait dans man et faire de
beaux bébés nageurs
arrêtez de nous dire que dire que
l'ascenseur social arrêtez de dire que
personne ne connaît rien le ministre du
budget et fear 2
et arrêtez un peu avec ce truc mouawad
est sûre j'ai pas l'impression de
darmanin et oublier quoi que ce soit
j'ai pas l'impression de normandie
oublier quoi que ce soit je dirais sont
ils sont tous voilà arrêté de plongée
qui sont tous eu des jets sont dessinés
avec l'état de noé avec l'employeur
d'argent dans la boue les deux normandie
île et que c'est quelqu'un ou en tout
cas que je sens très honnête et il le
dit clairement la question des quartiers
populaires et ne connaît pas et donc il
est à l'écouté et ça je trouve que c'est
justement il exactement
mais par contre quand vous me dites que
ce gouvernement est plein de gens mais
vous rigolez vous c'est une blague
non c'est une blague c'est regarder
alors dites moi quelle diversité il ya
dans ce gouvernement
actuellement alors dites moi c'est
qu'est ce que c'est la diversité des
universités
est-ce que c'est parti est ce que ce
parti de laurie d'uniformité
oui oui oui aux missions que moi je suis
un fan au risque d'une volaille d'autant
aussi et il ya les recycler ces jeux de
l'exercice et rouge et blanc ça serait
horrible mais je n'ai pas été sur google
je comprends pas bien c'est clair cette
notion de diversité moi je non j'ai pas
loin de parler j'en suis certain
facilité c'est comment est composée la
société française fait pas partie et
bien ce qu'on veut en quoi le
gouvernement et qui n'attire t il
faudrait quoi qu'est-ce qu'il faut
racheter gouvernorat les fonds qui
chantait deux profils oui
wanted est tous d'accord pour sortir de
la plateforme aulas nicolas sarkozy avec
des quotas par exemple bureau d'essayer
des quotas alors elle parce que j'ai
terminé en mai jean charest et parce
qu'une place est noire et pose des jo
d'annecy sur la parité déjà pas mal
non c'est vrai sur la parité au
gouvernement on a réussi mais sur ce
qu'il attendait les quotas oui il a
fallu qui met des buts alors cela
décante a partout ah oui bah oui c'est
la discrétion des questions de diversité
sur les listes c'est le drôle de tête la
solution c'est parce que ça oblige -
l'ailé mais ça va être dévolue et j'ai
vu opposer à ça pour montrer aussi
blessé qui lie le seul moyen mais c'est
peut-être aujourd'hui le sionisme
chrétien c'est comme ça que les
entreprises sont obligées d'avoir des
pourcentages elles doivent rendre des
comptes et ça c'est des contraintes mais
finalement ça se passe plutôt pas mal
enfin ça dépend alors on disait qu'il y
avait beaucoup de jeunes comme ça qu'ils
avaient qui avait soutenu emmanuel
macron pendant sa campagne électorale et
là il ya beaucoup de gens et bas qui me
soutiennent notamment le 5 décembre
cette grande grève c'est le débat le 5
décembre
qu'est ce qui va se passer maintenant
non c'était là c'était l'événement avant
la banlieue maintenant on va parler que
les débats c'est à dire le goût des 5
décembre
florent super calé vous connaissez bien
les rapports sociaux ou faux bond sait
que ça va être une grosse grève grève je
pense que ça va être dur
je sais pas ce que vous le gouvernement
va faire d'ici le 5 décembre
pour certaines c'est pas ça le problème
est dans un flou artistique contacter ou
compliqué mais comme vous disiez né dans
l'avant on va marcher oui on va marcher
beaucoup mois de décembre je pense mais
oui je pense que ça va pas oui ça va
aller mais en ce moment c'est
extrêmement surprenante c'est fort même
temps parce que c'est quand même une
grève du service public
les chefs d'entreprise ont l'air de dire
que d'en priver c'est plutôt calme et
enfin le 5 décembre
toutes les catégories de métiers qui
vont être qu'ils vont être dans la rue
ne serait-ce que de parler de mon métier
on a réussi à faire reculer alors pas
sur le thème de la retraite maison
oui avocats ils ont ils ont prévu une
réforme des tribunaux extrêmement
importante
il n'y a pas de décrets d'application on
sait pas devant qui on va devoir se
présenter au 1er janvier et c'est un
truc d'un match incroyable
il n'y a absolument pas eu de
concertation ni avec les magistrats demi
avec les avocats
et c'est ça quand vous dit qu'ils sont
un peu hors sol c'est un peu le cadre de
l'heure alors là du coup on les a fait
reculer la loi s'appliquera qu'au 1er
septembre parce qu'ils ont réalisé qu'on
n'a pas les outils pour faire
fonctionner les tribunaux 1er janvier le
1er janvier c'est demain quoi et donc
c'est un peu la même chose donc dans un
rapport la retraite c'est la même chose
pour la justice c'est quand même
surprenant qu'on parte on avance on fait
trois pas en arrière on dit mais on ira
jusqu'au bout mais en même temps
ce sera applicable peut-être que tous
ces problèmes si d'ici là il ya un
rapport immédiat problèmes financiers
c'est vrai que c'est un sujet compliqué
c'est pour ça que généralement les
allemands n'y touche pas sept noms et
philadelphie cette réforme là fait qu'il
ya énormément de français qui vont y
perdre dans cette réforme
oui en principe que puisque c'est ça moi
c'est quand ils disent on va égaliser
tout ça donc je vous égalisez il ya des
gagnants et des perdants 1
forcément est ce que ces mots ce que
cette boue critères le critères
d'égalité est ce que c'est le critère de
justice c'est à dire de savoir il ya des
régimes spéciaux il y en a qui sont sans
doute injuste il y en a d'autres qui
sont peut-être juste parce que ce n'est
pas sacré tas qui était plus intelligent
que celui de l'égalité de regarder ce
qui fonctionne qui fonctionne pas
pourquoi il ya des régimes spéciaux
est-ce qu'ils sont encore est ce qui s
qui sont encore aujourd'hui légitime ou
pas ces mesures prends l'exemple cher à
notre premier ministre qui dit est ce
que quelqu'un peut expliquer pourquoi un
chauffeur de bus à marseille prend sa
retraite à 60 ou 62 ans
et pour qu'un chauffeur de bus à paris
pour sa retraite à 55 ans est ce que
quelqu'un peut m'expliquer ça y est
autant de quartiers difficiles à
marseille qu'à paris c'est même bus
s'est fêlé papin de la même façon au qui
est très bien les médecins y aller même
sensibilité que c'était là pourquoi dans
ce cas des recettes ça n'a aucun sens ça
n'a aucun sens oui mais d un instituteur
il est mal payé toute sa vie mais il
choisit peut-être d'être instituteur
parce qu'il sait qu'il va avoir des
conditions de retraite un peu plus
favorable et très pernaut j'étais
persuadé que les enseignants s'étaient
par vocation pour ce qui est des
riffauds rien si ce n est que tu sais
quoi susciter des vocations et après on
est payé
on pense à sion qui c'est une
compensation qui ne cède pas si injuste
que ça laisse que je dise
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas examiné mais
que régime par régime celui-ci n'était
quel comité théodule va nous dire alors
ça alors bah oui au rostit les rappeurs
alors à l'uimm métier difficile et ces
terrains il se fait injurier dans les
dom duff dans ses concerts ça va pas à
la rue un métier difficile retraite à 45
ans ok très bien on va dire à ben
animateur à la télévision emballant là
c'est pas difficilement pu rester
jusqu'à 4 heures mais c'est ridicule
c'est évident mais c'est quoi la
pénibilité s'est tous serré débilité du
boulot et c'est tout à fait débouler ou
une engeance de la farine de travailler
à 75 la pénibilité la pénibilité elle
est reconnue et par ce peuple par ce
projet de réforme
cette réforme la retraite avec cette
communication illisible on ne sait pas
parce que il faut surtout pas de dés
l'âge 62 65 surtout parce que sinon tu
n'oses pas eu le françois mitterrand a
été élu en 80 avec le parti communiste
de georges marchais sous brejnev en
disant on met la retraite à 60 ans parce
qu'il était à 65 ans ça a changé le
chiffre depuis françois mitterrand il ya
peut-être des choses il ya peut-être des
choses à dire bon mais ce que je trouve
fou sans dents sedan ce dans cette
réforme de la retraite c'est qu'on a
l'impression que le seul but de la vie
c'est la retraite c'est à dire que la
retraite c'est la rente
alors on va tous être entier mais non
y'a d'art qui ont envie d'exercer leur
profession jusqu'à la fin de leur vie
alors aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que le
monde du travail est partagé en deux
c'est à dire ceux qui ont un boulot et
ceux qui exercent un métier ceux qui ont
un boulot alors c'est du genre dans les
bureaux ses dépens il leur faudrait une
rente
il faudrait que ça s'arrête le plus vite
possible parce que le labeur et trop et
trop et trop pénible et trop fatigant et
que j'ai un bébé né voilà il ya des
métiers pénibles bon ça il faut les
considérer
et puis il y a ceux qui exercent un
métier les enseignants par vocation
parce qu'ils aiment les enfants les gens
de la culture les médecins les avocats
légende de justice tous ces gens qui
exercent une profession
on leur parle aujourd'hui de la retraite
en disant bon ça va pas durer trop
longtemps tu travailles le moins
possible parce que le but du jeu c'est
la rente vous pensez que c'est un projet
de société de dire qu'on va finir
rentiers moi je suis désolé on va
commencer par dans l'éducation donné le
goût du travail le goût d'exercer un
emploi
le goût de de se spécialiser et de faire
un travail qui soit utile aux autres et
gratifiant et c'est sympa mais pas tout
à fait celle à qui on avait des lycéens
se mobilisent sur la retraite telle
société proposons nous justement c'est
la règle et non un problème il ya un
vrai problème de valorisation du travail
en même temps on est en train de dire
partout il faut faire plus avec moi oui
donc il ya un vrai problème aussi parce
qu'il ya une espèce de pressurisation il
ya un gros ce rebond moi qui fait du
droit du travail je peux vous dire que
là j'ai des dossiers en ce moment où les
gens partent en vrille et il ya de plus
en plus de conflits il ya plus en plus
de gens de dorna août et donc faut se
poser ces questions là je pense que si
on était plus un peu plus prendre le
temps que vous disiez d'être d'avoir des
moments où on est calme on a pas 150
mètres carrés dans la bon travail au
lieu de penser la retraite mais
reconnaissez que les gens qui ont
travaillé et qui est bon et qui pensent
pouvoir s'arrêter et gagner normalement
leur vie jésus nous sommes un peu un
tissu ne leur dis ah bah non peut-être
que vous avez rien touché ça s'est très
bien passé sur le sac le 5 décembre
les gens sont inquiets alors le
gouvernement veut parle du
du 5 du 5 décembre et alors les
journalistes pardon de le dire
les éditorialistes pardon de le dire mon
tout ça monte la mayonnaise parce qu'il
faut dramatiser ce 5 décembre
je suis alors c'est toi personne ne sait
ce qui va se passer ça se corse c'est
dépassé c'est la vraie réalité c'était
justement tu parles n'y a pas de
lisibilité
mais commençons par mira de lisibilité
dans le projet il n'y a pas de
lisibilité dans la force de la voie à
une période de notre vie on va tous
finir à l'ehpad
alors on est en train de nous dire on
est en bas oui on est en train de
préparer notre vieillesse et puis vous
savez ça va être de plus en plus long
parce qu'on vit de plus en plus vieux
dans connu et la torture va être de 2
mais c'est terrible ça longtemps avec sa
vie qui est beaucoup plus importante
après quand on prend sa retraite que le
temps de travail je sa guerre une jeune
fille l'autre jour deux parlent de la
retraite et je lui dis eux il est
l'outil arrive on n'aura pas de retraite
et je rêve et elle me dit je rêve d'être
à la retraite tôt et je dis qu'est ce
que vous allez faire la retraite
ah ben je vais voyager suivez vous
n'êtes pas du tout parce qu'aujourd'hui
vous travaillez vous pouvez dire tiens
je vais prendre dix jours de jouer poser
dix jours de vacances au moment de noël
parce que je vais voyager je suis en
forme j'ai du pouvoir d'achat
j'ai souvent un treizième mois eh ben ça
va me permettre de voyager et de vivre
et c'est normal d'avoir un travail qui
nous permette de vivre
on va pas attendre d'être entier sans
dents pour parler comme l'autre
cependant avec des prothèses pour
pouvoir voyager ça veut rien dire
j'étais pour qu'on ait koné 5 entre 20
et 25 ans pour profiter avec de l'argent
ça vas y j'espère y en a qui changent de
place qu'une minuscule que vous aimez
bien une ancienne milice martine aubry
qui luttait bec et ongles pour qu'on la
retraite les 35 heures plus à la
retraite on dira c'est scandaleux
à 69 ans il se représente pour six ans
alors elle est en retrait de dire c'est
bon pour les autres mais c'est quoi bon
pot est là c'est moi qu'on explique
michel thèze dogo des vocations
enfin une grande partie des jeunes ya
peut-être des jeunes qui pensent à la
retraite mais une grande partie des
jeunes ne voient les choses différemment
dix mois faire de l'argent ça
m'intéresse pas ce que je veux savoir un
métier dans lequel je crois qu'ils aient
des valeurs correspondent à mon état
d'esprit quitte à changer parfait un
fisc était responsable logistique est là
qui va sortir un album de rap pour
maintenant génial je surnommé sur la
question des retraites en fait le truc
qui se passe c'est que les gens sont
conscients d'une chose c'est l'enfumage
qui a derrière c'est à dire on va tout
droit vers la retraite par
capitalisation et qui rend service aux
amis du président de la république
ils vont faire le business
mais exactement exactement sur ses pas
il parle il ya pour les gens les plus
aisés c'est que quand les gens ont
choisi de le faire c'est une chose mais
on associer une solidarité quand même
n'aurait justement toute la france qui
est qui et solidaire c'est ce constat ne
sont pas dire ne vous lassez cela les a
mais c'est évident que c'est ridicule et
je le ferai mais discutait avec le
peuple monsieur le musée de votre
quartier ou de celui d'un jaune rappelé
gilles aux autres cépages et les noirs
s'agit des zones que vous ne rien voir
les amis du président mais c'est vrai
c'est en réalité des batailles en
réalité comme le débat d'arrière garde
que l'on entend à la sncf
à la sncf le gouvernement à sauver cette
entreprise avec la réforme de l'an
dernier et en reprenant il n'était pas
obligé d'être la dette de 35 milliards
d'euros pour que la sncf puisse bien
repartir sur ses pieds et sur tmc à tort
faut répondre c'est parce que le monde a
changé
mais oui alors justement c'est ce qu'il
faut le redire à l'hôpital l'hôpital à
33 milliards de dettes et en prix de 10
on n'a pas pu on n'a pas pu payer cette
dette
mais on a payé les cheveux les 35
milliards de la sncf l'an dernier bon on
peut pas tout faire l'hôpital c'est
quand même la chose la plus urgente
je trouve honteux honteux que les agents
de la sncf avec le cadeau que nous leur
avons fait avec nos impôts
je trouve honteux qu ils redescendent
dans la rue le 5 décembre et qui
bloquent le pays
alors qu'on a on leur a fait qu'une
réforme qui était quand même
particulièrement soigné l'an dernier à
quelqu'un qui ne sera pas dans la rue ce
soit dans la rue en décembre mais on va
passer à un autre sujet qui l'éclairage
c'est les violences faites aux femmes
c'est parce que c'est un sujet très
important
[Musique]
et oui c'est vrai que la société n'est
pas drôle au fond on est en train de
penser ça et la grève les bains vous
avez vu les trente les trente mesures
qui ont été annoncées par le premier
ministre à la suite du grenelle c'est
formidable vous les avez lu alors c'est
ce sont ce sont des mesures qui
ressemble aux normes vous savez concret
dans le bâtiment ont fait d'énormes
alors ça crée de l'emploi sa balle ça va
ça va créer des fonctionnaires alors on
fait je lis 1 un module de formation à
destination des personnels de
l'éducation un document unique un guide
réflexe à destination des personnels des
établissements
ensuite des outils à destination des
professionnels de santé parle pas des
fables a pour le moment
ensuite création de 80 postes
supplémentaires d'intervenants sociaux
instauration d'un parcours de formation
pour les policiers les gendarmes
c'est financé et ce truc c'est pas si
mal parce que jusqu'à présent c'était la
pleine lune était bien entendu ses
adversaires semblaient et dont les
femmes
ici on parle des femmes battues donc sur
les aider la cei pour les aider pour les
aider on n'a pas besoin d'avoir un
module de formation à document unique
des outils à destination ce qu'on sait
et la mesure 30 il faut ici c'est un
grand poème sa lame mesure 30 lancer une
formation en ligne certifiante pour
faire monter en compétences massivement
les différents professionnels qui
interviennent notamment dans les
établissements des services médico
sociaux
je vous la fais ok de choses qui sont
assez fortes et à sa famille non mais on
est dans une société dans laquelle elle
semble à la question de l'éducation
aujourd'hui il ya un problème
d'éducation et qu'il faut reprendre à la
base
oui et justement et ces mesures font
partie de ça les femmes quand vous les
entendez celles qui vont porter plainte
des fois elle vous raconte le périple
que c'est très grande et que la manière
dont elles se sentent humiliés une fois
de plus quand elles arrivent devant les
policiers qui leur pose certaines
questions et la manière dont ils et
elles sont suspectes d'ailleurs des
prêts à affronter arrive pour porter
plainte donc elles ont elles ont du mal
à le faire donc
les policiers ne sont pas formés ou que
gelson les formes est d'ailleurs un
policier à des salons mais peu importe
c'est pas une question mais alors c'est
pas fort mais ça veut rien dire non mais
c'est juste du bon non c'est exactement
le même problème que pour les femmes qui
arrivent dans un commissariat pour
dénoncer un viol je dirais l'arrêt
devant un petit peu cherché
mais oui mais là c'est un peu pareil
vous avez vu ces deux mois d'arrêt il
faut arrêter cette différence
la part de celles mot le mot est idiot
d'ailleurs 20 mai ce qui est marquant
c'est en effet ce qu'on voit bien c'est
que c'est la difficulté de ces femmes à
sortir de milieu familial dans lequel
sont battus que leur parole n'est pas
entendue
c'est ça la vraie la vraie question
après pour une fois je vais être
d'accord avec rost c'est vrai que quand
vous n'êtes pas nouvelle fois attentif
des banques dépend à la base de
l'éducation mais les gens il faut il
faut qu'on entier s'activent moi c'est
ça qui me fait le n'est pas parce que
maintenant c'est comment en 2020 quoi
pratiquement il y a encore çà et là avec
je sais pas combien parce que parce que
l'enfant reproduit sans trois de ses
connaissances mais c'est aussi parce que
quand même c'est quand même étonnant
pour que les sociétés un peu évolué mais
seulement nous sommes dans une société
où les femmes ne gagnent pas autant une
fan ne gagne pas autant qu'un homme
salaire un exotique mais c'est hyper
important comment est ce que on peut
construire une éducation des enfants à
qui on veut dire le garçon sait depuis
qu'il est tout petit que toute façon sa
soeur élève est moins bien pays retrouve
sa norme donc après entre 1 les moins
bien payés bombe fluctuations peut la
bousculer un peu les dominations c'est
un véritable premier césar ça c'est la
réalité
la femme est l'égalé de l'homme
payé du monde et ramadan c'est toujours
la haine de violence il ya non seulement
des violences physiques mais les
violences morales avec omission ou le
mari prend la carte bancaire les
chéquiers a là rien pour pouvoir faire
de bruit ça après sur des femmes qui
travaillent sur les femmes qui
travaillent donc oui j'espère d'ailleurs
quand elle dit quand on l'est aussi
quand on divorce pas tout scandale qui
avait eu au tel cet e3 cc c'est juste
qu'on a des féminicides on a raison de
le faire mais il faut pas que ça cache
non plus tout une situer tout un tas de
situations qui heureusement ne vont pas
jusqu'à jusqu'à la mort des femmes mais
qui sont des situations extrêmement
pénible à vivre pour elle
est ce que vous dites par exemple le
mari qui sont perdus du carnet de seigle
des salaires etc
mais ça veut dire qu'à l'école dès
l'école dès la maternelle il faut que le
chef d'établissement soit extrêmement
sévère sur les comportements des enfants
dès l'âge de 4 ans on ne tape pas une
fusion ne t'a pas une fille
on ne peut pas tout pour l'exercice a
commencé
bon maintenant mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que il faut que dès le plus jamais
ça que je la violence à l'école après
les dragons catalans subir la violence
on l'a sur les écrans maintenant il faut
voir aussi ce que l'on vient de faire
les enfants se gratter hd si vous
regardez toutes les séries préférées
comme ça c'est comme la violence c'est
un peu ce que nie en effet cathartique
et remettre son gardien de karaté bruce
lee des gens coup de mou de chacun donc
arrêtons
mesure dans les trois points on a parlé
il ya joué une demi phrase sur
l'alcoolisme qui touche quand même 40 %
des problèmes conjugaux et des violences
conjugales jusqu'à 40 % juste pour dire
ah ben il faudra faire attention à
l'alcool
non il ya un vrai travail de prévention
une mesure qui m'interpelle sur le plan
pénal donc là c'est un peu la juriste
qui parle sur le suicide force et
introduire le suicide forcé dans le code
pénal et je sais pas ce que c'est que
celui-ci de forcer sur le flop pénale
s'il ya des éléments matériels mais non
ça n'existe pas il nous reçut quelqu'un
alors il nous reste une minute quarante
je veux juste conduisant gaz du black
friday puisque c'est la seule à
polémique
non mais ça nous ait vu comment la
france et le nigeria il ya ceux qui
disent une aberration ceux qui disent
bon attendez vous êtes plaint que le
commerce marche pas à cause des gilet
jaune au moins qui vont marcher ce
coup-ci une augmentation de pouvoir
d'achat c'est pour dépenser sinon ça
sert un lavoir du pouvoir d'achat se
veut pas dépenser et ses comptes le
blâme pour quitte à dépenser si vous
vous dites vous acheter une télévision
essayer de lâcheté que joël coûte moins
cher qu'à d une augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat pas parce qu'on a son pouvoir
d'achat personnel qui augmente avec
d'une augmentation de salaire c'est
juste parce que c'est 30 %
c'est le temps du week-end wilson c'est
comme ça parce que ces blacks ou c'est
friday que c'est pas bien parce que ça
c'est quand même le vendredi noir c'est
le début de la crise de 29
1951 un article dans un article en 1951
aux états unis ça doit s'arrêter parce
que les les policiers étaient et était
fatigué de devoir travailler ce jour là
en plus et il y avait énormément de
monde donc c'était très noir les rues et
c'est pour ça qu'on a dit black friday
rencontre alors pardon moi je trouve ça
formidable parce que c'est le début des
cadeaux de noël ça fait et on se dit
mais ça a été contraint d'aider
démission maintenant vous êtes l'image
de notre société comme si c'était de
consommation à outrance et jette 2h10
d'ailleurs parce qu'ils sont moins chers
on achète un ordinateur datant de
l'année pour la schl et voilà c'est très
bien black friday mais vous allez adorer
le truc génial c'est que le black friday
jour de dure à peu près dix jours
maintenant donc merci à tous les quatre
je signale jean charles beaulieu est de
jean baptiste ferrero qui est un polar
qui se passe en banlieue qui se passe en
banlieue et qui est une une banlieue qui
plairait à rust parce qu'avec toutes ces
contradictions qaïda des caïds avec des
avec des religieux avec des gens qui
luttent avec des associations avec tout
le monde et c'est vraiment un monde
magnifiquement décrit et avec dureté
mais aussi avec un peu d'humour
le réveil est absolument merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup de restaurer leurs cadets
et jean charles lajoie dis à très vite
pour un nouveau prof
[Musique]